-Thank you!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Enjoy yourself.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here, you made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, everyone
is talking about this.
As of tonight's taping,
Republicans still
have not chosen
a speaker of the House
after Kevin McCarthy lost his
sixth vote in Congress.
[ Laughter ]
To be honest, it's hard to get
every Republican on board.
It's like getting 218 friends to
agree on where to have brunch.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
At this point,
McCarthy's so unpopular,
even Southwest Airlines
feels bad for him, you know?
[ Laughter ]
But this is interesting --
according to the Constitution,
if they don't have a speaker
by tomorrow,
the top contenders have
to compete in a dance-off.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
McCarthy has already lost
six votes to get the job.
It's pretty humiliating,
but he's not giving up.
He's even got
a different campaign slogan
for each round of voting.
Yeah, check this out.
For the first vote,
his slogan was...
For the second vote, it was...
[ Laughter ]
For the third vote, it was...
For the next vote, it was...
[ Laughter ]
Then, it was...
Next, it's...
Then it was...
[ Laughter ]
Then it's...
And finally, it's...
[ Cheers and applause ]
At least he's prepared.
[ Applause ]
That's right, lawmakers have
been staying at the Capitol
around the clock to try
and secure the votes.
And this is actual footage
of a delivery
that was wheeled into
McCarthy's office last night.
Look at this.
Look at all this pizza.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, that's real.
Yeah.
Sadly -- Sadly,
McCarthy lost three more votes
when he took a slice
of ham and pineapple.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-We don't do that.
That's right,
everyone sat around eating
while George Santos claimed
that his great-grandfather
invented pizza.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
The big news is that we still
don't have
a speaker of the House,
which means Congress can't
convene or swear in new members,
which means we don't have
a functioning government
right now, which means...
[ Dick Dale's "Misirlou" plays ]
♪♪
No rules!
-Hi, Mr. Fallon.
Ohh!
♪♪
-No rules!
-Ohh!
♪♪
[ Music stops ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Some more political news, uh...
[ Laughter ]
Today, President Biden
travelled to Kentucky
where he made a rare
joint appearance
with Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell.
It was actually
a very sweet moment
when they fell asleep
during each other's speeches.
[ Laughter ]
McConnell even got to ride
in the presidential limo.
-Ooh.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And unlike Trump,
Biden didn't have the car
suddenly pull away every time
Mitch tried to get in.
[ Laughter ]
"Come on, dude.
It's not funny."
Hey, guys, get this --
Donald Trump Jr.
posted a video
on Facebook yesterday,
and people noticed that he used
a lot of air quotes.
Watch this.
-But this is a person who was
wrapped up in that scandal.
She ran a fund
that was involved in it.
A "close colleague of crypto
King Sam Bankman-Fried,
Ellison is now pleading guilty,
saying she knew
what they did was illegal."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not sure Donald Trump Jr.
understands
how finger quotes work.
[ Laughter ]
At that point,
you're not doing air quotes.
You're doing a play
about two bunnies.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
And this is going viral -- on a
recent United Airlines flight,
one of the passengers lost
a pretty important item.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
-Anybody missing a cat?
No?
-I think it's
from way back there.
-Watch out, guys.
Anybody missing a cat?
[ Laughter ]
-Then, the pilot
got on the loudspeaker like,
"What the hell is happening
to the airline industry?
I mean,
we're dressed in suits up here.
What is going on with people?"
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, to cover it,
the airline was like,
"Tonight's in-flight
entertainment is a live showing
of 'Puss in Boots.'"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it's the first week
of 2023,
and with everyone making
their New Year's resolutions,
all the gyms are trying
to sign up new members.
Check out how one of them
is going after people.
It's interesting.
-If you're looking
to get in shape,
come on down to Planet Fitness.
We've got treadmills, weights,
ellipticals, TVs,
pool tables, stools,
beer on tap, jalapeño poppers,
darts, a jukebox,
and trivia night.
-Yeah, not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good idea.
[ Applause ]
That's right,
it's the start of the new year,
and we're four days
into dry January,
which is when people stop
drinking alcohol for 31 days.
Then on February 1st,
you basically hit your liver
with a flying elbow
off the top rope.
[ Laughter ]
'Course, a lot of people
are still talking about
their New Year's resolutions.
My resolution this year
is to travel more.
Quest, what's yours?
-Hey, I'm gonna go to the gym
more, you know?
My calves are gonna be
as buff as phonebooks.
-Nice. What about you, Higgins?
-[ Coughs ]
-I'm cutting back on smoking.
Now I'm on -- [ Coughs ]
just like three packs a day.
That's it.
-That's good. That's great.
James, what about your
New Year's resolution?
-[ Speaking Na'vi ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-[ Speaking Na'vi ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Come on.
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
What?
-Oh, my God.
Okay.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
He already learned Na'vi.
That's great.
-He speaks fluent Na'vi, yeah.
-He's a whiz with an air fryer.
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, I read that researchers
are working to develop
a new smart device that can tell
whether you have COVID
or the flu.
They even have
a good name for it.
It's called a COVID test.
[ Laughter ]
Stick around!
We'll be right back
with "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters"!